ein autofahrer in einem opel pkw 30
jahre alter mann ist dringend verdächtig
ich will mal dieses kasse words
verwenden als angemessen ist quasi jagd
gemacht zu haben auf motorradfahrer vor
wind er hat zwei motorradfahrer gerammt
ein pkw dabei gerammt und noch einen
weiteren pkw gestreift nachdem welche
erkenntnisse dass diese kollisionen sind
nach unserer derzeitige bewertung liegt
als unfälle zu bewerten sondern als
gezielte angriffe als anschläge auf die
anderen verkehrsteilnehmer
deswegen werden wir heute eine
vorführung wegen versuchten mordes in
mehreren fällen für jene von mindestens
drei fällen aus aber die ermittlungen
sind natürlich in der heißen phase noch
in der anfangsphase sie haben da noch
keine abschließenden erkenntnisse
es kommen auch noch weitere fälle in
betracht
der mann hat eben zunächst ein pkw
gestreift dann später ein motorradfahrer
gerammt
dieser motorradfahrer ist dabei
schwerstverletzt worden hat schwere
kopf- und wirbelverletzungen erlitten
der mann seine fahrt fortgesetzt die
stadtautobahn also beginnt in
wilmersdorf enden an der ausfahrt
alboinstraße hat einen weiteren
motorradfahrer oder motorrollerfahrer
pochiert angriffen und schließlich ein
motorrad auf einen pkw gedrückt dort ist
das fahrzeug zu stehen gekommen
der mann ist ausgestiegen hat einen eine
munitionskiste auf seinem fahrzeug
abgestellt die dann hinzu kommen einen
polizeibeamten haben das für einen
gefährlichen gegenstand gehalten davon
konnte man auch so wie das ausgehen
haben sie mal freundlich festgenommen
sind spezial spezialisten hinzugezogen
worden die die munitionskiste versucht
haben da fand sich mal gedanken werkzeug
drin
aufgrund der gesamtumstände aufgrund des
verhaltens der äußerungen des mannes
gehen wir von einem religiös
islamistischen hintergrund dieser tat
serie muss ich sagen der tat dieser
taten aus aufgrund der äußerungen des
mannes der gesamtumstände heute erfolgt
die vorführung wegen versuchten mordes
in mehreren fällen habe auch noch keinen
gesamtüberblick wie viele fälle sind
mindestens drei auf jeden fall
wahrscheinlich mehr und es gibt
abgesehen von der von der radikal
islamistischen aus der heraus die taten
offensichtlich begangen worden sind
motiviert worden sind hinweise auf eine
psychische labilität des mannes auch
diesen hinweisen er verständlich nach
das heißt daran orientiert sich auch die
frage ob er nun heute super last eines
haftbefehls vorgeführt wird und eine
untersuchungshaft kommt oder ob
möglicherweise aufgrund seines
psychischen zustands eine vorläufige
unterbringung betrag kommt da ist noch
keine endgültige entscheidung gefallen
aber die wird heute im laufe des tages
fallen